hi
how are you guys great how are you
i am very well i appreciate you talking
to me i have been a dancer since i was
four years old but i'm also six feet
tall so i never did point because i was
like there's just no way i'll ever have
a partner so i absolutely am the perfect
audience for this and wow
loved every second of all the dancing so
thank you thank you that's really
wonderful that's really good to hear
yeah
yeah that was like something i that's
one of my talking points is that i'm a
very tall person so i get it
today that's what you heard when you
were yeah i was when i was like eight i
eight or nine i used dance when i was a
kid for like a few years and then i had
my first growth spurt and they were like
you are going to be too tall to be a
dancer so like you shouldn't even try
and i was like okay i'll just do
something else then
and that was the end of it that was like
the end of my dance career yeah i was
like nine years old and became six feet
tall and they were like you're not gonna
have a partner so yeah you get it i grew
like six inches it was crazy and then
they were like you sorry anyway
well i wrote that this was a project
that involved finding a filmmaker who
could turn this into a film for you guys
which like how cool is that
what made you want to tell this story
what was it that made you see a movie in
this story how did all that happen
yeah i was i was working with sarah um
when
my manager first told me about the book
we were shooting looking for alaska and
she was um
an amazing support during that process
and so we had just talked about wanting
to do
something kind of physical and new
challenge and i was very out of my body
and i really wanted to explore certain
things
just within that and
female relations and friendship and
competition and as well as what my
character goes through which is you know
she just lost her twin her other half
and she's coping and she's trying to um
i don't know get by and and then at the
end of it
the way that she begins her healing
process was really powerful to me so i
was really excited about
about doing that and then diana was was
everyone wanted her to be involved and
i'd just heard of her but i was really
excited about that too and and about
kate's journey and and all that she you
know goes through and
all the different themes
yeah i
but by the time it came to me it was uh
sarah deanna smith is going to do this
film
and they want like
christine process is already like is on
board like are you on board and i met
with sarah and we
got a drink and she gave me this grand
pitch and told me all the things that
was going to happen in this film and
like what was going to happen with kate
and like can i
am i cool am i down to train for
to be a ballerina and i was like yes yes
and yes
so
it was just you know i was like
it would be really fun to explore
someone who starts off with such a clean
moral
moral
compass and then it's just like slowly
but surely deteriorates into like what
am i willing to do to to achieve
greatness
and i i hadn't played anyone like that
and that is a theme that i was like
really interested in exploring along
with like and
the um
with the the other world of of like this
friendship she has with m and like it
pushing
the boundaries of sexuality and like do
do i want to be this person do i want to
be with this person like i'm you know
all of these themes that come up
especially in that age like that coming
of age
time of your life i was like this sounds
incredible i would love to be a part of
it like when do i start training yeah
she got the bands out real quick oh yeah
by bands she means like like theraband
oh yeah sorry yeah oh you know you're a
dancer yeah yeah
yeah no because of that i know that
ballet is sort of equal parts beautiful
and terrifying
so i mean it's sort of like its own
horror film in that way like it just
seems medieval and also beautiful
yeah taking all of that into
consideration what were you most scared
about when it came to
you know playing a character at the
elite level i mean it just seems it's
hard enough to just portray ballet at
all but these are like serious
ballerinas
yeah i was really just trying to educate
myself and get in as much information as
possible and but also just knowing that
we did only have three months and
three weeks to do all this so we just
had to lower our expectations we are
very hard on ourselves
so i think you know we
they are
true athletes and
they train usually from as you know from
when you're young and we just didn't
have that and
that was
we didn't want to disrespect anyone we
also wanted to make sure we were doing
it you know as as truthfully as possible
but we also had to be realistic and that
was scary knowing that
we could we had high expectations and we
wanted to get as close to it as possible
but it is
impossible until at the same time to
yeah it's uh it's a pretty grueling
gruesome like you said like
like medieval yet such a beautiful
uh
art like creative art i mean expression
i don't even know like the right word
ballet so many different things it's
sport it's an art it's expression it's
like
it's it's rigid it's free it's like so
many different things and like trying to
understand all of that there's so much
opposition in like what ballet is and
how your body even works to to do ballet
yeah that it's like
trying to learn all of that in such a
short amount of time was really really
hard and and like christine said we just
were trying to
we were doing the best we possibly could
and like wanting and not and wanting to
be respectful of the dance world and so
we hoped that we were in this
film what was it like to see the
finished film and to see how all of your
hard work blended with the dance doubles
you had and i mean it looks so flawless
in this thank you thank you thank you
now that's special i mean i just
remember getting into our first tutu
and
we i mean i
i was already i was so tired already by
that point it only been three months of
of i mean shiny's training and i just
that was so rewarding and then to just
have gone through
the actual shooting and then cove it and
then
and then we going back into it and now
just like full circle seeing it on the
big screen was i mean it's really
rewarding
yeah i mean it was there were certain
scenes that like i mean ultimately we
learned all of the choreography and when
we would rehearse we weren't on point
ourselves obviously because that would
be dangerous and like irresponsible but
we learned everything you know like we
learned everything we
we did as much as we possibly could and
like ultimately i'm not even sure which
moments like obviously anything on point
like i know it's not me but
other than that like
i don't i couldn't tell you which is
like what you know because like
it mean you have like a team of people
that are helping you achieve like reach
a certain place the best to the best of
your ability it's like
it's i don't know it's like i'm like
really proud of the work that we both
did we were just consistent and we
always got back up and i mean we had
such a great space for it but yeah we
finished and we
gave it our all yeah we tried our best
even though you weren't dancing on point
did you ever put the point shoes on to
see what that would feel like
just once and they got mad at us
we had to like wear them all the time
like just in contrast obviously when i
tried to go my toes yeah when we were
trying to go on our toes we're like guys
but like we would like do it privately
although i feel like at the end we were
like able to like do it
i couldn't do that yes you could you got
a natural ballet fee get out of here
you see me like killing my theraband
trying to get oh my gosh
how did this whole experience feel
working with sarah adina smith through
this i mean you guys were on it from the
beginning it sounds like these you know
you were a part of your characters
evolving what was it like to be
involved in that way throughout this
is it hard to know that not every
project you do will be that way
yeah for sure i mean i don't know
every every project's different yeah i
mean you can't compare any of them yeah
like ultimately sarah was was the
captain of this ship you know so i mean
we're lucky that she
like wanted
was open to you know
how we felt about our characters you
know i can't speak for you but like she
was like open to hearing my thoughts on
kate or whatnot but um
i think i don't know it's like
there's what's on the page and then
there's rehearsal and then there's
like choreography and then there's like
on the day and really through those
rehearsals we built trust and
which left more room to play on the day
you know so
that's but ultimately sarah was our
leader she was the captain and she
she's she was our director you know and
so she was like really her vision and
her her story and
i mean
we i hope we told the story
to the best of what she wanted and
that's like yeah you know
that's like yeah
[Laughter]
well
it's said in the film that greatness has
a price and and when it comes to ballet
we can certainly see the toll it takes
you know on the outside of dancers
bodies
was there's anything that doing this did
it give you an understanding or an
appreciation of the dancers that do it
that you just had no idea of before
yeah it's like you have like an idea of
like what dancers do and the lives they
live and then you like like that old
saying like walk a mile in someone
else's shoes like yeah i've tried
putting on point shoes and walking a
mile and nose like you know yeah it's
ins they're insane like
their dedication
is
the discipline the
the sheer force of like will power to do
this
day in and day out the passion to do
this day in and day out for your entire
life is like
is so admirable there's so much respect
for them
right there with you especially after
going through all that
we did like three it was just three
months i know like yeah but still you
know it's not nearly as as yeah yeah i
have so much respect
do you feel like that there is a way to
achieve that greatness without
compromising your soul in some way like
all of these characters sort of have to
do i mean when you're
in a world like that that is so
competitive is it hard to avoid some
sort of compromise
and i'd like to think not i mean that
you can if you i mean you you kick this
through that so yeah i mean when it's
less about the validation i think i
think it's always for me at least it's
always going back to the intention of
why i'm wanting to do this and
and then i think always taking a step
back if it's
you know if it's like messing up my
mental health or like if there's certain
things that i'm realizing are not
healthy and then really taking a step
back and questioning
the path and the intentions like i said
and
um i think if you have that sort of
awareness you can hopefully create this
balance of
i think if you're also feeling
i mean we just talked about this in
terms of our own industry too of like we
feel like playing dirty means you don't
have trust that what's meant for you
will happen
you know and i feel like it's just
having that trust and that's that like
faith in the universe that
what you will not miss out on what is
meant for you
so
like just
keep on like focus on yourself on your
own path rather than like how do i get
rid of this person yeah there are no
roadblocks there are no like they're
only the only and your biggest enemy is
yourself your biggest competitor is
yourself like and you you you project
that part of yourself like the part that
you're insecure about onto other people
and things but like really it's like
it's so it's such so internal
you know and you just have to like
put the blinders on and like hone in to
where you're at
and like stop worrying about everyone
else and just let like let them be who
they are gonna be you know
does it feel like you sort of have to
get out of your own head the most when
you go into audition for something it
seems like that's the time where it's
the hardest to
you know not to not get too attached to
a role you don't know what you're gonna
play or to not worry about the other
people
yeah it's hard yeah it's been it's been
um
interesting with zoom too i mean
before i would find it extra challenging
when you went into space and you saw the
other girls that were sitting there and
i'd always get in my head about oh
either way yeah like we all look alike
and maybe they want that kind of version
and i have to do that or like sometimes
they would send girls home and the ones
that would stay i'd get in my head like
okay well why are they staying and i
would i would like
focus so much on everything else besides
just serving the story and and feeling
confident in the choices in my own
interpretation and hopefully being able
to adjust with the director and on the
day but
i um it's been a long i mean i'm still
struggling with like having a healthy
relationship with the ego and um and
you know
and not just yeah it's it's hard to get
the negative thoughts out
for me it's like
i i hate to i like hate zoom conditions
they're they feel so impersonal and i
feel like well i hate the process yeah i
said before it's like yeah yeah yeah the
moment before you're like yeah um but i
feel like it's like
for me it's like the actual audition
itself like being in the room that's the
best part yeah it's always waiting after
you know you're like oh god like did i
do
you know that's the worst part and then
being like who and then you hear another
name of who they like and you're like oh
man that's so different they're so cool
like when you know but the actual being
in the room and like getting to work
creatively with the people like that's
the best part
yeah it's like at a certain point you're
just like happy to be there and like
because you're you're acting you're
doing the thing that you love and after
that it doesn't even matter what happens
like really because then it that really
is just like the the
their vision yeah but the process is
really like if you don't love the
process then like you don't love the
thing itself no you know that's true
yeah
that's all we have is that yeah yeah it
just seems like with this it's the best
kind of circumstance because you knew
you would be playing these characters
and
yeah to get too attached to them because
they seem like how could you not get
attached to characters like this
yeah well
there's something about
this whole world that it feels like when
you watch this jacqueline bisset sort of
embodies all of that
so what was it like to
have the experience of working with a
legendary actress like her and just
she just was kind of scary in this to me
so what was it like to work with her in
these scenes and then
you know not
be interacting with her as characters
i mean she's just a force of nature and
it was amazing just to watch how focused
she was and how present she was and she
would always just keep you on your toes
like you could not not be present with
her in a scene and that was incredible
um and off screen i mean she was just so
lovely and you could ask her questions
and she would be there for it because i
feel like she was a little messed with
me i was like kate because i felt like
off's camera i was still like i want her
approval so bad
you know then on rap day it was so funny
because on rap day she was like you're
very talented and i was like you liked
me this whole time
but i think did she do that on purpose
because she i think she wanted to like
really keep us in this environment
because she i mean she knows better than
me like
you know working with someone like that
is so humbling because all you all like
you're in the best position because you
have everything to learn and everything
to gain from this person yeah and it's
that's the time when you sit back and
you just watch you know and you just
experience it it was she's she's
incredible
what's next for each of you do you know
what you're gonna be doing next are you
trying to figure out are there very
different things you have to think about
now that you're also working in a world
with all these new safety protocols
yeah i mean i um
i just wrapped on another show that was
really fun where i got to play betty
ford and and she's meant a lot to me and
all that she's done with the ford center
and everything that she's you know the
how much she's talked about addiction
and all that so that was incredible and
that comes out next year and i have
another movie coming out but i'm just
hustling yeah
i just celebrated this and you know onto
the decks we'll see we'll see what
happens
i just i mean i filmed scenes in two of
space force um
this
last like april to june
it's been like hard with the pandemic
because you know pre-pandemic you could
do you could work out two projects at
once yeah now it's um so
you know i've had a couple things that i
wasn't able to do because of my
commitment to a show to my show you know
um and i feel like you know it's hard to
say what what the world would look like
if there wasn't covid but like the
reality is you know you have to kind of
really
just be patient and like what like i
said earlier it's like you will not i
know i won't miss out on like what's
meant for me so i'm just gonna celebrate
this and
you know keep on keeping on keeping on
good mom what is the experience of doing
that show like because it seems like you
know kind of a wild experience
it's really fun um
i i we were in vancouver for season two
because like kobet and uh greg daniels
was shooting his other show already in
vancouver so it was just like it made
sense to just move us up there
um so i think it was just really really
fun and like we had a good time and
we kind of forgot we were in a pandemic
which is the best it feels good when
you're on set and you're just so present
with the people that you're with that
you like which is like it was like with
birds of paradise too like even though
we had kobe going back for round two
like it didn't really feel like that
because we had our own safe space and
that's like same kind of thing up there
and lots of karaoke nights oh my gosh
that's amazing we watched
yeah i mean i don't want to spoil my own
trust but i have to do that later but we
watched a lot of like 90s like
blockbusters together which was fun
yeah face-off insane film wow fantastic
thank you both for talking to me about
this you really do tremendous work on
this i was so impressed with both of
your performances
acting and dancing in it so thank you
thank you so much for talking to me
about it thank you have a good one